MISS MINUTES
Welcome to the Time Variance Authority.
[Loki grunts]
MISS MINUTES
I'm Miss Minutes, and it's my job
to catch you up before
you stand trial for your crimes!
So, settle in...
LOKI
Now, hang on just a minute!
MISS MINUTES
...and we'll get you in front of a judge
in no time.
LOKI
[Laughs] Who actually believes this crap?
TVA AGENT
Sir, let me see your ticket.
MAN
No.
[Man screams]
MISS MINUTES
Thanks for visiting the TVA.
Don't hesitate to
let us know how we're doing!
LOKI
What do you want from me?
MOBIUS
You put our timeline in chaos.
I want you to help us fix it.
LOKI
What could possibly go wrong?
JUDGE RENSLAYER
Trusting Loki is not a good idea.
LOKI
Do I get a weapon?
MOBIUS
Gear up.
TVA AGENT
Absolutely not.